hey I see your comments I see them I
know I haven't posted a video here in a
while um settle down it's okay
I've actually been posting a ton of
videos your eyes just not looking in the
right place
[Music]
check out my other iJustine channel for
a bunch of videos from your way but the
real reason that I have not been posting
is busy traveling and climbing glaciers
she's gonna cause an avalanche a glacier
and an ice wall a wall of ice I'm gonna
be posting a full video of my collation
hike very soon and I can't wait to show
you guys that because it's pretty much
unlike anything that I've ever
experienced if you guys have climbed a
glacier before you know exactly what I'm
talking about and if you haven't be very
very careful but in other news the new
iPhone 4s is out and for those of you
guys that weren't aware of the ordeal
that I had with Apple to actually get
this phone let me just share with you
this quick little clip that was minutes
after I opened up the box that was
supposed to have my iPhone 4s in it and
it contained nothing they forgot to put
the phone in the box either way I went
the next day ended up getting the phone
and on this phone contains my new best
friend what's your name my name is Siri
but you knew that already
I did she's she's right Siri what's my
name your Justine that's what you told
me anyway
Siri Jenna is my homegirl okay do you
want me to remember that jenna Marbles
is your homegirl yes Siri do you love me
I'm not capable of love Siri who is your
daddy
my daddy yes sirree who is your daddy
you are can we get back to work now
series you said that I'm her dad Siri
what's my favorite color I don't know
maybe the Genius Bar folks can answer
that she just told me the Genius Bar
folks could answer that Siri where did
you come from
i Gerry was designed by Apple in
California you do realize that you are
ruining my life
right if you say so
and as you can see I basically have no
need for any more human interaction
which is creepy on that note I am
working on a serial of song it's pretty
funny so hope you guys like it and if
you don't like it well too bad it
happens it's the internet everyone's
allowed to have their own opinion um I'm
gonna go I love you guys thanks for
watching if you want to check out some
more of the Norway videos that I've
posted on by their channel I'll post a
link in the description and oh oh yeah
so I'm working on mask edge episode and
I was looking for questions on YouTube
but I realized that I never actually
tell you guys to ask me any questions so
feel free to leave your questions below
in this comment box down there so that I
can answer those for the next episode
see you guys then
I love you bye
stop recording Siri
who's your mom no comment
[Music]